ああああ
ああ
長崎刺繍職人のかせて歌と申します
私は刺繍をやって40年になります
セシウムや6人間です話しすることは大変
歌なんですけれどもしかし長崎刺繍に関し
て私が知ってるっていうかはことはこれは
話す必要があると思いまして今回
引き受けることにいたしましたつ違い
シャベルとなりますがどうぞ
をつけるほどよろしくお願いします
長崎シュートはどういうものかと言います
とこれは22本4春も一つの下だですね
まあこれはもう間違いないところですけど
それはどういうステできたかと言いますと
長崎の歴史と深く関わっております
その
1600年ぐらいからですねまぁ鎖国と
いう状態になってまぁ明治維新まで
鎖国そして回昆布ライダー唯一の貿易港と
してですねあの長崎という港はあったわけ
です
その間にポルトガルオランダ中国東南アジ
やそういうところからいろんな文物文化が
入ってきたわけですねしかしながら
マーシュ日本にはそのキリスト教弾圧
禁教令ですねそういうことで非常に悲しい
歴史もあるんですけど
しかし本来長崎っていうのはポルト
バザールによって開かれた港でまぁ言えず
不可エリアの
量を寄進された町でもあったわけですけど
もねそういう歴史もある街です
で長崎の秋の祭礼長崎くんちというのが
ありますけれどもこれにあの衣装とか出し
として
使われていたのが長崎市しようというもの
でありますでまぁここにちょっと展示して
ありますけれどもこれが長崎刺繍のあの
代表的というかマーカー船の衣装なんです
けれども明治の頃できておりますまあ上は
このスタンド側ですねスタンドからので舌
はを捜査の種みたいなもんですけれども
これは明治に制作されて a
目は吹きガラス大変こういうところ銀座
井戸ですね本金の禁止を使ってこれを子供
が来て奉納するというまあこういうこと
オーグやって打つときたわけですけれども
この奉納っていうのがですねあの今でも
そうなんですけども受け所から7年一度
出すという
そして7年に一度というのは結局1年私
たら次の7年後にしか出せないという
まぁそこにですね町の誇りをかけて新規性
のあるですね創造性がある富裕な
風流んですねそれをねそういうものを出し
たわけですねじゃあいつでもこう
ワクワクするようなものを出そうという
気力に満ちてたわけですそして長崎の町民
の街ですけれども本当の自分家の交流に
長けている街となっていきます
ところで刺繍の世界に入る前私が餌を志し
ていました
まあこれは高校の頃ですねまあ
御多分にもれずセザンヌ
まあこれ大好きですけど今でももちろん
好きなんですけどそういうものを
から入っていってまぁ東京でちょっと
いろいろやっとったんですけどもその時に
はだいぶ経ってからアメリカの現代絵画の
ですねジャクソンポロック中その
ドリッピング中央
ようですねまぁを正していくんですけども
まぁ壁にかけてありましたけどねまぁ笠鉾
と同じまあ6メートル上の長さの大画面で
したけどもそこにへ溝がずっとたれていっ
たというか誰だしたらたぶんっ
そういう表現になんてたわけですねそこの
時に作者のその息遣いを凄く感じまして
ゾクゾクっとしてました
またもう一つ
その頃であった
印象深いいえばやっぱ鳥獣戯画ですねこれ
はまあ高山寺ですかねあの
鳥獣戯画有名ですよね
カエルさんとかウサギさんがあの
相撲とってたりですねソースしますけれど
も実に線が美しいですねそれにもう一つ
びっくりすることはまあ品もよりも
ちょっとアニメっぽい中ですよねちょっと
どこを気がということでね以前で楽しい会
になってましたよね本日にこれもあのなん
か印象に残っている ao 志していた頃
の印象に残っております
しかしながらまあ創出こうしているうちに
も30になりましてこれはどうもならんと
いうことで30で戻りまして長崎に戻り
まして唯一上っていた
刺繍天理で修理しました
それが青春の世界の始まりです
まあ刺繍っていうのはですね針と糸で
ちくちくやっていく世界ですけれども
まあこれがですねだいたいその当時はあの
まあ三首相もまだないころぐですね花門亭
の皆さんご存知でしょうか赤門っていうの
はあの
スタートか産めば時とか5さんの兄とか皆
さんの故にも多分ありますあるはずです
サーモン好きというもんくらいがあります
んでね
そのあのまあ女性の場合は特にいっしょ
直径2センチぐらい黒ぐらいの
思い思いをを作るわけですけれどもそれを
あの
欠失打って言いましたよね糸を撚った糸を
釣っ着点後を付いてずっと
一番シンプルな形ですけど点だけでマール
だったりさ三角だったりですね葉っぱだっ
たり作るわけですけどもその時に着物の背
につけるということで鬼門っていうのは右
身頃左身頃って二つに割ってられるんです
ねそうすると右半分左半分半分ずつの縁を
つなげて一つのきれいだ丸率
しかしその土台が通されているかと言うと
気が張ってあるわけですね記事が張った
るってことは下せば知事のっていう状態な
んだからその力加減と使命加減ですねそれ
に点を突いていくて後をついていくんだ
けれどもまああの
結局縦糸横糸の関係で言いますと上の方は
ティ
横井たり直角にかかるせ
横の方は縦糸に直角にかかるそういう
ところで同じ消し次ぐ同じようについてい
くっていうことのそれだけて勝負ができる
世界のですねまぁ1個の点が2個になると
宣言あり3つになると曲線になるこれは
ちょうどにあるとすごくあった受けた師匠
気になるわけですお願いですね未だリンは
難しい良い姿勢まあ刺繍のもう一番なんて
言うんですよね
面白みでもあるところですそういう世界
ですもう一つ刺繍っていうのはですねこれ
はですね家なんですよね会ではあるが人は
糸を見ているというそういう状態なんで
すっで素材とした絹糸っちゅうのはすごく
美しいものです艶があります
しかし湯を見せながら糸を見せるという
これはどういうことかするトリックとか
マジックとかそういうママに近いんです
そこには何が必要か釣ってる仕掛けなん
ですねその仕掛けっていうところでですね
色んなまで糸の撚り具合とかあの
をしたりちょっと膨らみを入れるとか
いろんな
てる手段があるわけですね
まあそれともう一つありだとかその刺繍
aider あるからには何かないです
からというとした衣が大事なんですねでも
主体は
会なんですけどそれから方っていう人に
翻訳する形に変換せないかその時に
下絵がよりシンプルな人に変換しやすい形
にもう一つ方にしなくてからそこも大事な
ことですね
そしてまあそういうことを勉強しながら者
が少ないときには私あの
古い刺繍の訓示の補修をやっておりました
双方して時間が過ぎていきました
流さ下君使える江戸期の刺繍はまあ優れた
ものがいろいろあるんですけれども
ここではもう各84年180年ぶりに復元
の仕事としてでっ出会った万屋町の笠鉾
ウォーズ串の話をします
傘ボコッとはどういうものかと言いますと
ですね角を取る必要がああ
自分の町の長印ですねその長の一番高
代表的なデザインというんですかね長印と
して奉納するほかのだから祭りの奉納に
対して一番ふさわしい図案を持ったまあ
笠鉾のツアーになっていくわけですでこの
万屋町という長は捕鯨の
ありさまを
奉納という形で出しております今も
もちろん立ちます
a 笠鉾のたではですねだいたい長さが
直径2メートルの傘に1.5m も下がり
って言いますが擦過音がつながってるん
ですけどそこに刺繍がしてあってまあだ
からだいたい6メートルの長さ
それにたては1.5m ところに始終がし
てあるわけです
でこれがですね万屋町は1827年に初代
a それから48年に時代ですねそういう
ヌイ氏が差したという記録が残っており
まして下絵は腹南嶺されている長崎の医学
さんです
ココアの鯨の潮吹きというですねあの奉納
踊りを出すわけですけどもその漁労に
ちなみですね16種29匹の魚がまあこれ
長崎近海で捕れた魚んですけれどもデリ
浮上に盛り上げて付けられております
まあこのあの
復元を依頼された時にどうしたかと言い
ますとですね
まあこれと同じものを作らんっていうか
ただいま江戸切絵てきたちょっとこう
できたてもモノにしたいなという気持ちも
ありましたけれどもまず
世襲の魚まあこの場合帯だったが最初だっ
たんですけども大谷分から迫ってくるは
ですねあの対応型が1m くらいのたい
ですけどそれをまあまずどうして発注です
ねとレースですねうん魚をあの
立体初3 d ですねちょっと盛り上がっ
てるもんですから前半へのものより
ちょっと輪郭ヒロインですねその部分を冬
洋榎ながら必要そのとレースをしました
それともう一つはですねそのタイの生きた
対応スケッチしましたこれはもう魚屋さん
に行って生きたのんまっいいか食べました
けどね a
ただ園に泳がせて下絵を描くっていうです
ね昔の文献に乗ってたんですね制御と修行
の違いに非常にこだわったと命をこう
行き来したものを作りたかったんですよね
それでまあもう6今日よりもですね魚を
確保する狂気が非常にかかったとそういう
逸話も残るておりますそしてここででき
ましたのがこれがさえっ会の実物大のあの
型紙ですけれどもこういうえおお答えて
これがを原寸の大きさんですねここに今
秘伝とか a ラプターとかですねあの
まあシッポまあ別々に作ってこれを合体し
ないですねセビ女子行ったりさんが作って
いくわけですけど本モノはどうやってた
勝ち残りですねいたが実に見事が流れて
かかっているわけです
この流れによってボリュームを出している
わけですね
そしてまどっかでこうスーッとなくして
いくとかですねまあそういうまあそれた後
4色もですね先染めの糸っていうかある
程度大きなそういうのはあげたいとをし
ながらマスター箱中原は背負ってやってる
んですけどそういうものを作って3種最終
的にちょっと彩色もしてあるわけですね
まあそういうものを
江戸期のものはしてあったわけで私もこれ
をしようと思ってまあその通りにですねだ
言っても間違いなくやったつもりですけど
も1年半かかって
できました女はですねあの吹きガラスです
そしてまあ取り組んでですねまず隊は完成
したんですけれども取り組んで3年目の時
ですね何匹目た作ってただけですまだ最初
の頃ですね
あの
クエ不明だったですね死体が発見された
ところニュースが入ったんですねどこで
発見されたんかちょっとローンどうなん
ですねえっビックリしましたなんだ
ロンドン加藤よけどまぁねスコットランド
の方っていう話も聞いておりましたので
まあこれそういうあのロンドンの
オークションにかかっていたわけですねで
自分とのテレビ局に連れて行ってもらって
ですね実際見ることができましたこれは
ですが大きさを持ったあの笠鉾と同じ大き
さなんですねまぁそれにですね線が美しい
星色も残ってるし
それに何無料というっていうのはですね
まぁマッサージそのう
なんて言うんでしょうかの
たいうかにいろんなものがですね3次元で
表現してあるんですねまあ魚 v 図鑑で
はなくてまさにですね鳥獣戯画みたいな
感じですもうその美しさにでびっくりし
ましたここでホント若い頃見た鳥獣戯画と
も
なんかで同じ想いを見たるべきました
そしてそのラージ巻物として大きさに
かかっていたんですけれどもあの
ワシントンの p バーディーセックス
みゅーじまあそういうところが落札しまし
て長崎に開けませんでした幸いですねその
時のオークションのカタログが手に入って
をいましたのでそれを持って帰って
笠鉾の同じ大きさに拡大コピーしてあの
釜玉に断交 pot その
拡大さ刻印を得る乗せたとき比例ない最後
まで一致したんですねこのときの驚きは
もうほんとあの忘れられませんそして
それぞれにですね伊藤よりとかいろんな魚
がいるんですけどこれみんなですね歌舞伎
みたいに見えを切ってるんですね普通の
あの
巨類図鑑ではなくてあり得ない方向に背が
向いてたり捨てですねしかしこれ実に好
日本的な見栄を切った目が鋭いいい魚たち
が入っておりました
3次元度
ああホルモンが実に型でしたね
その
すべてだを二重にさらにですねあの
縫い c まあこれ二人かかっておるん
ですけどね時ですねあの文化文政の頃です
よあの
職員玉宗で縫い上げたもうその見事な
出来栄えですねまぁさん事件って表現に
まあしたい理由目だったんですけどそれ
ちょっとの盛り上げそりゃわざと過去より
言って膨らませてより高
ディアンヌな家よりもですねあのーああ
いいんでしょうかねより生命観を持たせる
ようなことを言いとしたんだと思います
そしてまあ人の面白みます引き出してです
ね
ふぐでは原の山新たところですねあので9
なると勝頼と言いますけれどもそれと普通
の撚りの糸を重ねて詰む這わせるとですね
そういうざらつきのある平面になったり
だろう腹になったりですねたこの場合には
吸盤のところずっとした滑るみたいなもの
ですね呼ばない糸ですね使ってあの
4体とのへのせるっていうことですごく
多いとの表情をうまく以来ながら
タコの吸盤を出しましたまたたり至った
その絵はですねエラーの2ボタンを下に偉
そうものを指しておりましたかでですね
ただここは誰も行きたいというそういう
ところまでこだわっております伊政府の
コーラー右寄り左寄り同じ糸ですかのより
が違うという形で作っておりましたですね
餡子の口の中もうこれはあのそ通りところ
まで設置に行っております
しかしですねこれあのねぇ
ほんとキリがない表現はまあ今でいえば4
件8型の世界ですねまあ5ミリ角と僕ら
もう自分たちであるそう思ってるんじゃ
指してるのが5ミリ角の創部だと思って
やってるんですけどその中の1本美しさ
ですね一粒一粒てがよりの一つ一つ勝つ
やがって育ちがいいですね時計させた職人
のですね息づかいまで感じられてですね
これはもう別れて組た頃ジャクソン
ポロック3トンを見たときと同じような
間隙を受けました
まあこうして1010年各12年かけて
ですね魚づくしが完成して無事フォームを
することでできました
その後鯨を捕る船長あ船の多さですねそれ
をらせん道って言いますけどその身長依頼
を受けることができましてまあこれんどは
慎重までですからあの2今まで任されたん
ですねそしてクジラを奉納する町のその
プライドというかモチベーション
どうどういうものかと思ったぜいろいろ山
を考えたんですけど結局
背中にスクリーンでもつけてしを
吹き上げる潮は銀細工というですね大胆な
ことをやろうと思いましてそこそうやった
んですけどもその時に何が一番気になった
かというとですね奉納された9時座の日
着物の女ですねこの女が悲しい目をしたの
でまあ強いてレアの能面の綿みたいなもん
ですねってまぁその音はですねああ
何と言いましょうか
マートライブから正しいんですけれども
まあそれ以上に何か人間を生きていること
の悲しみみたいな言葉であるんじゃないか
と思ってですね私はさしました私の願いと
思うと技の集大成として3年かかって
作り上げました
まああの長崎刺繍というのは永作人の誇り
であります完成歴史
a を入ると着る人によって縫い上げた
ものです
war 族車ですね今市の文化財になって
おりますけれどもこれはもう奉納から解放
されてですね今はもうあの大臣線って漢方
子世界的な貴重な主だろうと思いますまあ
良いものはですね古今東西軸を超えて人々
に感動を与えますまあこの中で中止が続い
ておりますけれども年来そうですねこの
新調した衣装をみなさん方に見て頂きたい
と思っております
この万屋町の鯨
これがですね福を招くという意味で版芸
招福という米をいただきました
まあへ臓器の職人魂を100年後の人々に
伝えたいものです